let's get started we're gonna talk we're
gonna keep talking about polymers today
um uh polymers uh that's also gonna be
the topic
of uh the quiz and because this
uh you know because of the exam and
everything and so we
we're having our second lecture on
polymers today the quiz tomorrow will be
at the end of recitation
so that you can have a full second
recitation on this topic
um okay now um i'd like to pick up
what i mentioned on monday right monday
uh we introduced polymers and i i
covered two different ways
to make polymers okay um
on the one hand let's write those down
let's
write those down with chalk which is
somewhere
here we go on the one hand
we had
what we called radical initiation so
radical initiate right we use the
radical initiator remember this
r dot and we talked about radicals
okay and how that can lead to this kind
of chain reaction
right and so these are and so this this
is called chain
polymerization uh sometimes it's called
addition
polymerization but it all involves
a radical to start it uh and then
a double bond remember we talked about
that double bond the importance of the
double bond
right so this would have like some
monomer this would have like some
monomer and
it but it's got to have a uh with a
double bond that's not an equal sign
that's the double bond
now the second way we talked about was
called condensation polymerization so
condensation
polymerization these are two ways
we covered that allow you to make
these these really really long chains
that's what a polymer is right
polymer mer being from say hundreds to
thousands and even millions
and in condensation polymerization you
would have
two different you could even have more
two different monomers two different
monomers
and these two different monomers uh well
let's write it explicitly they react
okay and they react because they've got
this uh
these n groups that uh that when they
see each other
right from one monomer to the next um
they form
a bond right and in the case that we did
on monday
uh they formed an amide bond
and they gave off water right so water
left
so when you do condensation
polymerization you start with two
different monomers
they've got the end groups on them that
when they see each other they want to
react
you wind up with a polymer
that weighs a little bit less than the
two monomers right
because you've given off water oh you
could give off other things
there's a lot of examples so you give
off
in the reaction you give off maybe h2o
like we did
could be could be hcl
it could be nh3 there there are a number
of ways i don't want you to get the
feeling that the only way you can do
condensation polymerization is
is the nylon example right there's a lot
of ways you can do this
but one thing that is that is certainly
true is that in forming that bond
you give something else up so the total
mass is it and that's why sometimes
people like calling this
addition because in addition
polymerization right when you
when you take a monomer and you just
keep adding it
and the sum is this is n times
the monomer right the sum of the weight
whereas in this case
well it's a little bit less because you
did a reaction
right okay so that's all kind of getting
us back in the mood that's what we did
on monday now today i want to talk about
the properties of polymers and how we
control them how we can change them
different ways that we can change it i
can't cover everything
but i want to cover some key elements of
engineering polymers so we're going to
talk about the properties
and a couple of specific things that we
use to control them
so we will so let's start a list here in
the middle
and the first thing is something we
already did talk about monday which is
just the monomer itself
right so so what is it that matters in a
polymer what is it that dictates
what a polymer will be like
right well one is the monomer
so that's the unit oh well okay we just
said you need two here
so maybe there's monomers
but that's the unit that you're
repeating clearly that's going to be
really important right what did you put
there
right is it c2h4 right is it
polyethylene or is it something else did
you add something to it the benzene ring
right um and and so that's going to be
really important the other thing that we
talked about
and so we're going to create this list
is the molecular weight
now remember molecular weight
oh we like you know every little
community likes to come up with its own
names
we we know grams per mole and then and
then they
say oh that's a dalton and so now we say
okay a dalton is a gram per mole
kilodalton would be a thousand grams per
mole
and but we also said that this gives us
the degree
of polymerization so that's really
important right because
how much the degree of polymerization
well i mean if i know what my myrrh is
and and i know the molecular weight
the grams per mole of a strand then i
know how many mers went into it so i
know the degree of polymerization that's
just
n right it's some number but
but this is important um
and you know i'll put it over here so i
can keep going down on that board
when you have a uh
a synthesis of a polymer it doesn't
matter which one of those you use
you're going out a hundred thousand
units
i can't say well every single one is
going to be a hundred thousand that is
really really hard to do so instead you
get a distribution
so when you say the molecular weight
what you mean is some average
right so this would be like maybe the
molecular weight
maybe this is in daltons maybe it's in
kilodaltons
and you say oh the molecular weight is
40 kilodaltons
no that's the average right
you might have ones that are way way
longer out here maybe
orders of magnitude longer this can be
this distribution can be orders of
magnitude
but it still can be you know you can try
to make them longer so you have a
distribution that's more out here or you
make them shorter
right so this is something that is
important and that can be engineered
you can imagine if my chains are really
really long
then maybe it's a tougher material right
because because there's just more
covalent bonded backbone to break
right you can imagine that that might be
one thing
oh but the thing that we gotta gotta
talk about is
is the chemistry which dictates the
bonding
and that's now that's a okay so the
chemistry so the interactions
and this this takes us back
to so many happy moments from this fall
where we talked about
intermolecular forces all of those apply
to polymers
they all apply what are the imf's
well so like if i gave you an example
like a question
okay maybe maybe you could say well
let's see
uh okay i've got poly
ethylene so this is the uh
okay this is the way we remember this is
how we we write
it and in this case i've left off my h's
but the little sticks there means
there's an h above each and below each
one
uh i've got polystyrene so that's
polyethylene
here's polystyrene here i'm just
remember this one has a benzene ring oh
that's a terrible
drawing of a benzene ring but it's what
it's supposed to be
they have to come out of the parentheses
if it doesn't come out of the
parenthesis it's not a polymer because
you're not indicating repetition
right okay that's supposed to be benzene
and that would be poly um polystyrene
and then
how about another one how about uh i'll
put it here
how about polyvinyl alcohol so
now watch this i'm going brackets
because
remember it's okay and
so here o h
right and each one of these would have
some number of repeats
that's pineal that's polyvinyl alcohol
i can say well look just look at those
monomers
just look at the mers right remember the
monomers
if if these were made with with chain
polymerization the monomers would have
would have a double bond
right remember that right but and so
this is the repeat unit
in the polymer that's what goes into the
brackets or the parentheses
that i could look at and say which is
this which one of these is going to be
the strongest
right mechanically and you know from
your imf days you know
which one it is because only one of them
can form a stronger bond than london
they're all going to have london
everyone has london
but this one has hydrogen as well
that's got hydrogen bonds so the
polyvinyl alcohol will be stronger
right that will be the stronger one and
you know and you know that that bond is
going to be in there
it's going to bond to other hydrogens
from other chains or maybe
from itself because remember this is
what
it looks like but even much much much
much much more
these are macromolecules these are
macromolecules
okay yes but
now i'm going to take i wanted to put
these here so i have them so i'm going
to take
one of these which one is it it's
polystyrene
it's this one with the very poorly drawn
benzene
and i didn't change anything about it
but look at what it can do
that's polystyrene in three different
forms
they're all cups but they're you know
these cups well right one styrofoam
one i don't know what you call that but
those are pl they're all plastic cups
but they have very different properties
they have the exact same
polymer polystyrene
how do we do that that's not the imf's
it doesn't even have to
it doesn't have to have anything to do
with the molecular weight it could
no it's something else and that is
the density oh and so now we get to talk
about density
and crystallinity
and i just saved
three letters this makes me very happy
now crystallinity
crystallinity density memories
good memories very good memories are
happening right now
from when we talked about amorphous
materials and the glass transition
right because remember
i drew this on the board let's see
let's get these to come down
what that actually looks like
what that actually looks like each
strand
in there remember goes like this and
then it's like oh wait i can make a
crystal
and then it's like nope i'm amorphous
again and then it's like oh wait hold on
i can crystallize right here and then
it's amorphous again and this is so
fun and then you go like this and that
and that's one that's like one one
hundredth of a strand
and so the question so you can you know
that the crystalline region
what do i mean by crystalline well the
strand is stacking up
in some ordered regular repeating way
what do i mean by amorphous well every
i mean spaghetti
but but a polymer in its own strand can
crystallize
to some extent or to more or less right
and that's something we can control we
can engineer that
and that's what leads to these
differences because
it you know that in a crystalline you
know region
it's going to have a low a lower volume
right is going to take up less volume
that's what we did before with glasses
so let's put that on the board right so
you know
that from our from our good old days
that if i melt a material well it could
form
a crystal that's temperature and this
would be volume per mole
right this would be like the melting
point it might form a crystal but with
polymers
imagine i've got the spaghetti strands
and now they're miles long
it's really hard to line it all up and
and so
a lot of it will not find that that
place
and instead it will be a glass which you
know
is another way of saying so these are
now tgs
right tg and so you know now
uh all about this right and you know
that cooling rate
is one way to to to change the density
to change the volume per mole right
so so how so the density of the
amorphous region
uh is one parameter that that could be
glassy
in different ways like we did before and
then how much of it you can make into a
crystal
is another parameter both of which play
into the overall density
and crystallinity right both of those
are
extremely important and those are going
to depend on all sorts of parameters
related to the processing and the
temperature
and so forth those are the things that
can lead to
changes like this from the same exact
chemistry
so if you look at let's let's go from
polystyrene
to back to polyethylene
right so if you look at polyethylene
so this is a list i showed i think a
version of this on monday
and these are all these are all uh
it's hard to read don't worry about it
it's these are all you know monomers
and this is the polymer they didn't put
the brackets there but you could see oh
maybe they did
yeah kind sort of um you can see the
line
right coming out that's the repeat line
um
and and this is the monomer notice the
double bonds ready for
chain polymerization right and here are
the properties near the uses but i want
to look at this
ldpe and hdpe
now ldp and http so uh so that's
low density and high density of the same
exact polymer
so the interactions are the same right
but all we've done is we've changed the
density and the difference between the
properties
is tremendous so when you go to the the
grocery store and they give you a
plastic bag
which you'll wind up feeding to fishes
in the ocean as you now know
um the uh it's very soft it's the exact
same material that's in
over 30 percent of all toys on the
planet
it's still polyethylene all we've done
is mess with that
we've messed with the density
the density so how do you mess with the
density how
well we there it turns out with polymers
there are different ways
you can do this one we just talked about
so one let's do a little uh okay
no no i'm gonna do this so one would be
uh let's say co processing i'll call it
processing
that's right here how quickly did i melt
it right what were the conditions
that i formed it in but see i could you
can imagine
changing its ability to crystallize our
pack by just changing
something else about the about the
the the polymer itself and so another
way to do that
would be to change the physical
structure
of the chain physical structure
and there are two ways that you can do
this
oh boy let's see how am i gonna continue
this
okay let's do this ha
bullet one one way is called branching
and another is called tacticity
so what are these so branching
is exactly what it sounds like because
the the polymer that i showed you here
is just you know this is a mess and it's
showing how it's a spaghetti chain but
notice that it's just a line
everywhere it's just we would call this
a straight line
this is a straight line it just kind of
wanders around
yeah okay we can because it's in
contrast
it's in contrast to
if it if it's a straight line then it's
sort of locally straight
but what if it did this
right then it's like which way do i go
right that's it can be the exact same
chemistry but because maybe
one of those radicals in the soup while
this was being made came in
and got to move a hydrogen around in
just the right way it was able to start
growing off of the side
right that's a branch so
you can imagine that controlling this
branching
would be a really big deal in terms of
the
the crystallinity right so if you go now
if you go to
pasta it always seems to come back to
pasta
maybe it's just me i don't think so
though i think there's something deeper
about the pasta in here but
see this is a polymer
yeah but if i but you can imagine now if
i make spaghetti
and it looks like the left it's all
packed in but what if each spaghetti
it's actually an interesting idea for a
new pasta brand right
and what if each spaghetti strand looked
like that
and and now you take those and you try
to make your
but it would be actually pretty cool but
it wouldn't pack as
well you can feel it with the pasta
right you can feel it it's not it's
going to take up more room in the bowl
and it's the exact same thing with
polymers so
if you want a polymer to be stronger
to have maybe more crystallinity or or
higher density
hdpe then you don't want
very much branching so you better dial
that in
when you synthesize it you better think
carefully about how you're making this
to prevent
those kinds of side chains from growing
okay
well tacticity is another thing and and
that's
not the same as branching tacticity
is remember you know like in in uh
where did it go i had it up there but
so tacticity is whether you there's a
benzene ring
which you know are they all on the same
side
are they on alternating sides how did
this how did this thing go
did two go on the same side and then one
and then and is it random
i mean you could imagine that if it's if
it's kind of if i have
a way to break the symmetry of the tr of
the chain like this
then you can imagine that if i break it
a lot
so i'm a tactic then that's going to be
harder to line up as well
right that's going to make it harder for
the spaghetti
to kind of fall right and be right next
to each other
but if even if the spaghetti had little
you call these little
mini benzene branches it's not branching
but you can call them like little
branches but if they're all on the same
side then you can imagine they can still
stack
really well right so when you have
side groups like this this is another
aspect of engineering the polymer that
you've got to think very carefully about
because if it's isotactic or
syndiotactic
then it's going to be so that's the
physical structure of the chain
then it's going to be able to pack more
easily and it's going to be stronger
right if it's a tactic and then you
we're talking about like 100 degrees
same polymer same chemical
unit make the molecular weights the same
all you've changed is
whether there's symmetry or not and you
can change the melting point by 100
degrees
right of the same material so that's
another way that we engineer
the properties of polymers okay
same polymer garbage bags to tupperware
same chemistry isotactic to a tactic
okay now um wow
now we get to something really fun which
is
crosslinks and and and this is
this is number five okay so we're
talking about ways to control
polymers cross-linking
is one of the single most important ways
to engineer the properties of polymers
and it basically is exactly what it says
you're linking
two different polymer chains together
across
cross linking okay
now it turns out the one remember i
showed you the video of the nylon
uh it's called the nylon rope pull if
you want to see that again
google it it's so cool uh you you have
two liquids with the two you know it's a
condensation
polymerization example two liquids with
two liquids with two different monomers
and you pull a solid out of the
interface
that's this that's exactly this and
those are
the molecules these are the monomers
that were in the liquid and there's the
there's the this is nylon six six
remember it's because you have a chain
there
and this is what you get and it keeps
repeating and there's your polymer
but look at what the reason i'm saying
that nylon
actually crosslinks is because of
something very important it's not
just that that these have you know
different interactions with each other
no it's something a little bit more than
that so if i look at this
and say okay here's a carbon and a
nitrogen i'm going to just try to draw
a part of this carbon nitrogen
there's a hydrogen and
oh boy here we go here's an oxygen
okay and it goes on oh i'm not gonna
draw what's in there it's six six
and then comes uh another okay nitrogen
hydrogen and then it goes up to a carbon
oxygen and then ah six six
or whatever it is right and then it goes
to a carbon
and oxygen like that and this goes to
uh nitrogen and so on and so
on but look oh remember this is called
the amide bond
that's cool right that's the bond that
formed
that's that's the amide bond that's the
bond that formed it's polyamide
right we we did this on monday
but now uh okay but look at what happens
so
so if i have another one of these that
comes up
beneath it i'm not going to draw the
whole thing i'm just going to draw that
part that has
the amide bond you can see that if i
have an oxygen here
with the carbon and let's do oh boy
nitrogen and like that okay
and so on then this if this lines up
but but it can line up and and then over
here you've got
a hydrogen and so you can get this kind
of really nice lineup
to form a hydrogen bond
between these chains you can
it can happen and that can add as we
know
that can add strength to the material so
that's a cross link because it's a very
specific linkage between these
these strands right it's not just sort
of an
average over different types of bonding
it's a specific link
that's in the chain well it turns out
that okay that just seemed to happen
because of the chemistry that was there
it can happen
but look we can also make it happen
we can engineer polymers and we do
to have all sorts of cross-linking
chemistry
right and it's really one of the most
single important ways
to control the properties of polymers
right so i want to talk about that
a little bit and i'm going to do it with
the the
maybe the most well used at least
example
of uh of the of what a crosslinker does
we're going to talk about rubber now
rubber is is a natural polymer you can
get it out of trees
right i think maybe i have a picture
yeah i do
oh poor goodyear but we'll talk about
him in a minute
um but there's rubber coming right out
of a tree
and when we see rubber in in this class
we think of isoprene
and isoprene is is this molecule
okay so here's isoprene there's a ch3
and then there's a double bond to a ch2
and another double bond to another ch2
now the the polymer that is coming from
this
rubber tree is
well it's polyisoprene okay so so matt
now okay i've got two double bonds
we're going to talk about a second but i
only need one to polymerize this
i only need one right and and so if i
think about this
i can make a polymer out of it and the
polymer would look like this
this would be polyisoprene okay so h
i'll draw the h's in just so we keep
track here's another c
and this has my oh boy i said i'd draw
them
and now i have to once you commit
all right there it is h right and then
you've got the double bond in there and
an h there
and then you've got this okay
ch2 unit there oh and that is
polyisoprene
it's it's not it looks complicated it's
got
you know a ch3 unit and some ch2 units
but here's the key
it's got left over a double bond
and that's the key now
you see that double bond i can do more
chemistry with
i can do i can do cross-linked chemistry
with
and the story of right so i started with
two
and i'm left with one because i needed
one to to make the the hundred thousand
long chains of these things
right so this is isoprene
and this is polyisoprene yeah but the
thing is that polyisoprene is not very
useful
the mayans used it people tried to use
iso
poly isoprene directly from nature for
centuries the the mayans would
because it's soft you know it's it's
like a mold
it's just really cool mold and probably
at some point somebody stepped in it
and they're like look my footprint and
it stayed
and so then they what they did is they
made boots out of it
and so they would put their whole foot
inside of a bucket of isoprene
and then it would sort of mold really
well right
and they'd make shoes that way now the
problem people tried to do this much
later too
the problem with making a boot out of
natural rubber
is that the natural rubber doesn't hold
together very well
so like seriously on a hot day the the
boot melts
which is not what you want people made
clothing out of it too
jackets were made with a poly with poly
isoprene inside
of two fibers but then it would melt and
get like sticky
right like on a summer day or if it
rained out
right so you had some issues with with
rubber but people really wanted to make
something out of this stuff it seemed
really neat
it could kind of be strong but not but
then very moldable
right and so along comes charles
goodyear
and he accidentally left
rubber on a stove with sulfur
and literally the way the story goes is
his house started smelling like burned
rubber
which was probably the first time ever
that smell was was made um
and what it had what he found was that
this rubber
was completely different when it was
left on the stove with sulfur
it all comes back to the double bond
it all comes back to the double bond why
because
now i've got a place where i can add a
covalent link
and that's exactly what sulfur does all
right
so if i take now uh
if i take this uh this i'm gonna try to
draw it again i'm not gonna draw the
the h's this time so i've got this and
here's that
that special double bond right and then
i've got this and
this okay that's that's natural rubber
but now
see with the double bond i can remember
these are what are these well these are
four electrons
but if sulfur comes along i might be
able to take two of them
right and and move them like this
and that's exactly what if sulfur comes
and offers something
that the carbon wants right like hey
come and bond with me
it'll be more fun maybe we'll go to a
lower energy state
right and then the carbon's like you
know what i i get that
i'm that sounds pretty cool i'm going to
give an electron from this double bond
i get to stay connected here with a
single bond right
and then i can be here and here and the
sulfur
can provide that other electron and form
a nice single bond
right that
because there's that double bond you can
do the chemistry
to create covalent strong bonds to
sulfur and then you get like another
sulfur
and another sulfur and so on and these
can be maybe
you know two three four sulfur units
long depending on how
how you cook it and then this will come
and this comes down and finds another
one
finds another strand and it finds the
double bond
that's in another polyisoprene strand
that's called cross
that's that's purposeful well accidental
he was a tinkerer and he played with
lots of things and his greatest
discovery was completely by accident
and he never made any money off of it
goodyear tire this is charles goodyear
goodyear tires this is a company it was
called the goodyear
vulcanite company
goodyear called it vulcanization and the
reason is vulcan
is the roman god for fire and he
he accidentally left it on the fire and
so that's called vulcanization
because of that right so this was this
used to be the goodyear
vulcanite company it's now goodyear
tires right
um and what happened what happened is
this those sulfur bonds that came about
accidentally the covalent bonds held
that material together
and it gave it a controllable
flexibility
and hardness right that's what they were
after
that's what they were after flexibility
and hardness
and so and so what
you know what is actually happening in
this
well what's happening is you're you're
adding these covalent bonds between
these very very long strands
right and so you can imagine that if you
if you you know if you pull on that
material now
well the long strands can detangle
so in the in the rubber tree these these
long long long long long strands
they're all wrapped up it's a spaghetti
bowl and i start pulling and
and they don't break but they start to
kind of slide and detangle
right and eventually you just break it
all apart
but now i've got a lock on it
because each little piece of spaghetti
is tied to another one somewhere
so i can untangle them only to a point
and then these these linkages kick in
and they're like no i'm sorry you can't
stretch anymore
right that's what the cross-linking does
and it gives it that strength
and so you can imagine if i had more and
more crosslinking
i might have a stronger material right
the stress strain curve could go like
that
if i not much crosslinking a lot of
crosslinking right
right because more and more of it is
going to be dictated
by these linkages here between the
strands
and then there's something really cool
that can happen with crosslinking
because this is an example of a covalent
bond
this is covalent
but crosslinking can be cross thinking
can be
let's see it can be covalent
it can be hydrogen we already saw that
there's sort of natural crosslinking in
nylon because of that hydrogen bond
you can introduce hydrogen bonds as well
you can be purposeful about it by the
way you can have an ionic
you can you can put any kind of bonding
that you can dial in and there are
different ways to do that
can become a cross-link opportunity
right so you can just imagine how much
this opened up polymer design how much
this crosslinking opens up polymer
design
now um so let's go now there's a there's
there's a downside
as well but first let's say positive
let's go to your goody bag this is the
chemistry inside your goody bag
right now this is a very purposeful
right these are the borax crosslinkers
you've got that in your bag and you add
it in and what i
want you to do is get an actual feeling
for
the cross sinkers right and and so you
can add more and you'll feel the
material change
because you're linking more and more of
it but see in this case it's a hydrogen
bond
you see that so those are the bark
crosslinkers
those groups keep their ohs and then
those ohs
there's the polyvinyl alcohol i drew
that on the board somewhere
before and and those ohs can now bond
to the hydrogen of the oh in the in the
pva
and that can form a crosslink but
there's something different about this
one
and it's so cool and that's why slime is
so cool
and and silly putty right because
now there's a time scale involved
there's a time scale involved so now you
can you can
pull it very slowly
and the hydrogen bonds that are
crosslinking have it
have time to change to move
to reform maybe they break and then they
reform
right um but if you pull it really fast
those hydrogen bonds don't have time and
i'll show you a picture in a second
um and so so what can happen now
is the the mechanical strength of this
material the brittleness of it the
properties of it
can literally just depend on how quickly
you pull it because you are up against
the speed of hydrogen bond
forming and reforming and that is
incredibly cool
you are literally feeling the formation
the destruction and formation of
hydrogen bonds
but there's something else that's going
on in this that's also so cool
this material slime that polymer
is is below its glass transition
temperature
sorry above i meant above
what does that mean it means that
without the cross-linkers
that polymer is a viscous liquid
it's this you remember the we drew it
somewhere
i erased it i erased it above
if you're below the ground the glass
transition temperature
you're basically like you know a solid
like a brittle solid
well like i drew polymers have polymers
are
amorphous maybe with some crystallinity
but but
a lot of it's going to be amorphous
maybe all of it
and so it you know it's going to have a
glass transition temperature
and and if you're above that it's this
viscous liquid it's this like super
cooled viscous liquid
but what i've done with the crosslinkers
is i've said hold on
you can't go away so i'm literally
making a solid
out of liquid you say yeah just put
like water in the freezer no that's not
the phase of that polymer is liquid
it is a viscous liquid but it is not
allowed to flow
because or if it does it maybe can
change its shape a little but it can't
just flow all over the place
because of those crosslinks right and
and that's an elastomer and and if you
do it just right
you get a viscoelastic material
and what do i mean by that well all
these things have to line up right
the thing has to want to be a liquid but
the crosslinkers so it's got to have the
right glass transition temperature
but the crosslinkers are are sort of
holding it in place and the crosslinker
chemistry has to be the right strength
it can't be too strong
can't be too weak right and again by
accident you might make
uh cross-linked silicone oh there's the
goodie bag which is silly putty
and that's why i wanted to give that to
you because this this hits all the right
combinations in this case the
the backbone is is made out of silicon
right
uh not carbon but it's the same thing
it's the cross-linking that
that does this so there's an example of
silly putty
which you all have in the goodie bag and
if you stretch it slowly
if you stretch it slowly those uh
hydrogen bonds
the the strands can kind of pull away
and those hydrogen bonds have time to
slowly
form and reform that's why it kind of
feels the same
nice elastic right
depending on the material on the
backbone it might go back as well
in silly putty it kind of just keeps on
still strands just keep on sliding
and the hydrogen bonds keep reforming
but if instead i pull it fast the
hydrogen bonds don't have time to react
that's why if you pull it really fast
like okay this is don't do this somebody
shot a bullet through it
it breaks like glass because if you do
that with silly putty
and you can feel it in your hands just
pull it really fast the hydrogen bonds
don't have time to reform
right and and so what you're left with
is you're just breaking apart this
material
now how elastic it feels right
how viscous it feels all these things
these are going to be be determined
by the glass transition temperature the
temperature of the room
right um and and so so that's going to
you know depend on whether you actually
have a liquid you know a very viscous
liquid or maybe you've got a solid then
it's going to be more brittle
all of these things are now at your
disposal
to tune the properties of the polymer
right they're all at your disposal and
it's
it's incredible to um to think about for
me at least holding together
a liquid in place like that and that's
leads to viscoelasticity viscoelasticity
right that's just viscous liquid in
elastic okay now
there's a couple more things that we
have to talk about and on friday
what i want to do fridays i want to come
back a little bit to
some of the ways that we're trying to uh
maybe engineer polymers to be more
like like nature right maybe
to try to solve something talk about yes
uh monday
if you want to try to solve the problems
try to do something big
and i gave an example of an ocean
cleanup project but the ocean cleanup
project won't matter
if we keep dumping more and more plastic
in the oceans it doesn't degrade
so we have to think very carefully about
what kinds of plastics we can make and
the problem with with crosslinking this
gets to the
the negative side right and this is a
way of categorizing these things that
i've been talking about
is it if i cross if i cross-link it a
lot we call that a thermoset
we call that a thermostat well why
because when you heat it up
thermo it's set so what you mold it
and then and you've got your little
crosslinker you know you pour your
sulfur in
and then it it's got a very high number
of crosslinks and you can see it there
right and and it gives you very strong
material
but you can't you can't break it back
apart so it's
very hard to recycle it's almost
impossible
if you try to heat these back up they
just burn usually
and if you melt them they're not usually
that useful because they've got all this
other chemistry and it completely messes
with the polymer
on the other hand the thermal plastic
has this kind of plastic deformation
i think like a maybe like a garbage bag
right so it can really
stretch and stretch and stretch but so
but it it it doesn't have the cross
sinkers
that's why you can do that but uh
but but then and so this is actually
much easier heat it up
melt it and you can reuse it so that's
that's a recyclable
uh polymer but um but the
the issue there is it's very difficult
to get all of the necessary
mechanical properties from these
thermoplastics
and so elastomers which are maybe
lightly cross-linked
polymers right
that are that are above the glass
transition temperature often
those are somewhere in between but could
but most of the time if you crosslink
even if you crosslink lightly it's very
difficult to recycle
and that's a really good problem because
maybe we can come up
with crosslink chemistries that are
reversible
right that give us an opportunity to uh
to have the best of both worlds it's
elastic when we want
it's it's uh it's deforms when we want
and it's solid when we want
oh and by the way you can degrade all
those crosslinks and reuse it
that's the that's like one of the the
dreams in in
in making environmentally friendly
plastic see you guys on friday
you